our next uh speaker is Longo
he's my piece she's doing he's awesome
he gives great talks I can take no
credit for any of this it's all him just
in case you were wondering yeah all
right thanks for the introduction Ryan
so I'm gonna talk today about
conditional hardness for mcsp and and
the back of uh back of I think all of
our heads is this question about whether
mcsp is MP complete and uh my goal in
this talk is so that for the people who
are maybe not so familiar with the
results about mcsp the hardness results
of that mcsp to tell you
um what the main results we know so far
are kind of what the main techniques are
and what the next steps are so I think
uh hopefully this will be useful uh if
you want to attack the problem this
semester uh giving you the background
you need for this thing
so I also
because this is a two-hour talk in the
afternoon I I have some trivia which
will be a little fun but we'll get to
that later
so
we're on day two of meta complexity you
guys have seen a lot of meta complexity
problems you know we have the complexity
zoo I think there's also a meta
complexity zoo and there are many many
problems here and um I think all of
these problems going back all the way to
K complexity which have a long history
and there are many many results about
them
but today I mostly want to focus in on
this problem mcsp your friendly
neighborhood meta complexity problem one
because I want to limit the number of
definitions that you guys have to keep
in mind so I think by concentrating on
mcspeed uh it will help you guys be able
to follow more of the talk and more of
the ideas especially to the people who
this is new for and also because I think
uh all of the major techniques and the
main story towards NP hardness of mcsp
can be told via variance of MCS uh mcsp
and its close Brethren so
you know they're going to be some many
results that I won't cover but hopefully
I can get the story across to you
using mcsp
[Applause]
so at this point you guys have seen uh
this slide or variants of this slide
many times
what the minimum circuit size problem is
so I probably won't get into it but just
uh to do a quick review you know you're
given this truth table of a Boolean
function you're given a size threshold
and you want to decide
does your truth table have circuits of
that size
and something that's going to be
important throughout this talk is uh
this question
what notion of circuits are you
considering and we'll see various
different types of circuits uh for
different circuit classes we have
different hardness and different
techniques that we're using to prove
that the problem is NP hard
okay and as we all know by now this is a
problem in NP that's probably not in p
uh one thing that hasn't been discussed
so far is
there are really no non-trivial
algorithms from csb in fact I don't I
don't even know if there is an algorithm
as far as I'm aware that saves like a
constant Factor off of The Brute Force
algorithm from CSP so it's kind of an
interesting problem in that it seems
like uh we can make no progress on
algorithmically and uh
this question of proving it's NP hard I
think is especially interesting because
like we have like no algorithmic ideas
on how to attack this problem
okay so this is this is basically what
we know uh or the basic complexity of
mcsp probably are there any questions
about this probably this has been
covered
all right so the main open question as
you can probably guess by now and the
topic for the socket is what do we know
about is mcsp
and I also want to mention
there's kind of a bigger question which
is the approximation version uh of
NP hardness
so is mcspnp hard in this talk we're
going to cover various uh techniques and
partial results that kind of show work
towards showing is
the decision version of mcsp where you
have to exactly calculate the circuit
complexity of the problem is that MP
heart and I think the techniques we have
so far are really building towards
showing that's NP hard
but for some of the applications that we
have like connections to average case
complexity and so on uh it's somehow
more important I like to call this
problem distinguishing order from chaos
we heard it earlier as structure from
Randomness to distinguish whether
um you're given some truth table which
is either really ordered has circuit
complexity entered Epsilon or it really
has very little order has complexity n
to the one minus Epsilon and this
question is really seems to be more
mysterious we have techniques and and
we'll go into later in the talk
shuichi's result about some partial
version of mcsb which which gives
hardness of a variant of mcsp with some
weak in approximability but this bigger
question about uh
whether the in the large approximation
regime the problem is NP hard is
something we know less about yeah so
this is kind of the big picture I think
that we want to be working towards I
think understanding this is what I'm
going to tell you about a little bit
more about it in this talking but uh I
think the ultimate goal to really
understand mcsp is we want to understand
this approximation version
[ __ ]
so the roadmap for this talk I guess my
arrow really didn't show up on here but
uh you can see it over there on the on
the sideboards so
um in this talk I'm going to start by
recapping some of the motivation for why
we want to understand this problem is
empty heart and I want to specifically
talk about that from the NP hardness
standpoint and then I want to tell you a
little bit about the barriers and this
is probably going to be like uh the
first part of this talk this first hour
of this talk is mostly going to be about
motivation barriers and a little bit of
the progress we've seen so far and then
the second half of the talk is going to
be the results that we have uh more
about the progress so
okay
so
why do we care so much about NP hardness
and mcsp there there are several reasons
and and we've seen some of them so far
one reason that I want to talk about
that we haven't talked about so much uh
Rahul mentioned it briefly is it's kind
of a very like historically interesting
problem I like to joke that it's a
question older than time and space
you'll see why later sometimes
complexity classes
um
and the study of mcsp started in the
Soviet Union around the 1950s so these
people were interested in the question
of like which problems require Brute
Force search
what problems can you not solve without
just having to go uh through all the
potential possibilities and seeing
whether they were
and kind of interestingly their
candidate problem was the minimum
circuit size problem which I think is a
really funny because it's like a problem
today we don't still don't know how to
beat groups especially by a constant
Factor so this was a really good
hypothesis and you know this is really
before complexity theory was really
started they didn't really have the
tools to to analyze this question which
makes it really easy amazing that in
1959 uh a Soviet scientist named
yavlonski basically claimed uh he had
proved that mcsp is is not in P of
course there wasn't the language for
that yet but this would be really
amazing because if ubonski's proof was
correct he would have actually resolved
P versus NP before it was even stated
um and so at least so far
as far as we can tell this hasn't
resolved the problem he was really
looking at a specific case of algorithms
for mcsp we wait why would it result
when you
why would it resolve
D oh oh because
um mcsp is an NP and then if it's not in
P then uh P must be different than
anything yeah
yeah so he was interested in this
question of whether it requires group
for a search and yeah so we had this
it's uh probably it okay let's say much
more about that although it is kind of
funny that
um in an unfortunate event yabotsky
actually got into power in uh the
scientific community in Soviet Russia
and so it actually became hard to work
on this problem of whether mcsp requires
parabor because it was kind of
politically difficult uh when your
boss's boss's boss thinks he's proved
that uh it's intractable and you want to
keep working on the problem so uh is
something that maybe was not so great
for research at the time
and uh so just to justify my title the
question will live in time and space it
took like another six years for a Time
hierarchy theorem heart modest and
Stearns to Define these time classes
these space classes
and then one other
okay I guess uh yeah you can see my
Anonymous person on the TVs uh one other
thing that that kind of happened out of
this Parable research which I thought
was kind of fun I mentioned it to you
guys is uh
uh the scientist Dr unfortunately
couldn't find a picture of him motivated
by trying to understand these Parable
conjectures actually effectively ended
up proving that P is not equal to NP
relative to Oracle again before like NP
is really defined and this is like
before gilbaker solve a so that's kind
of some interesting history so the way
they refer to it is what like the best
algorithm is Brute Force search that's
how they stated it yeah so there's this
uh server by attracted route where they
they talks about in more detail but
that's that's basically how they stated
it
um yeah
and uh okay in 1973 11 comes onto the
scene with uh his theory event Peak and
fleetness and as Rahul mentioned earlier
he was really interested in uh only by
extending this Theory event be complete
list to graph isomorphism circuit
minimization or with less hope factoring
um
that this Theory would be interesting
and uh
I think uh good thing he published it he
tried apparently he tried for a long
time there's a blog post about this on
Levin's blog which is very interesting
but uh if you're interested I can send
you a link to it later and then dot dot
dot until uh I want to pull out a quote
that Ryan made it at the Simon's lower
bound seminar probably I think on this
stage uh four years ago when he was
talking about mcsp and he has this quote
if it's a NP complete it would have to
require techniques that are not like any
polynomial time reduction that we have
ever seen uh I think uh deterministic
polynomial time reduction is what he was
referring to in context
but uh so this is kind of this history
we have this history going back all the
way to the 1950s that this is some
problem which doesn't seem like you're
able to solve without doing Brute Force
search and so at least this is
historically interesting question
and uh you know okay but maybe you don't
care about history you know uh why do I
want to show that mcsd is going to be
hard what do I care
um and this motivation that we've seen
earlier is uh eliminating heuristica so
there's this theorem by hirohara a
really amazing theorem I like to call it
a death star theorem because uh you know
NP hardness of mcsb is gonna destroy
this world of heuristica uh
where I get to see whether the Death
Star will be operational but
uh yeah so here is stick uh I guess you
you were you were supposed to have seen
this uh talk on average case complexity
earlier but probably you already know
what here stickers it's this world where
status worst case hard but easy on
average and this is a this is a problem
uh uh eliminating heuristica for which
there were many barriers whether there
would be like uh non-black box barriers
relativizing barriers revelization
barriers and here how I was able to
weaponize meta complexity to get a
non-black box reduction so understanding
NP hardness of mcsp in this case
actually uh for this specific result you
need an approximation to mcsp this is
like this order versus chaos problem
that I talked about earlier uh if you
get that then you can destroy heuristica
so this is one I think really good and
motivation to understanding that mcsp is
NP hard not just intractable but NP hard
happens
another motivation that we're going to
hear about tomorrow is about basing
one-way functions on fever sent p
here I think is like uh I I think this
is a meta complexity dream but I guess
it's more of a cryptographer's dream but
uh if you could prove the series of
implications you know if p is not equal
to NP uh then mcsp is a hard and worst
case so this is the NP hardness of mcsp
uh and does that imply mcspring average
and does that imply one-way functions
exist
this would be really amazing because now
you have one-way functions the
foundations of cryptography based on uh
P naught equal to NP and this has been
like a long-standing goal for a while
and you can ask uh you know
uh what what progress have we made to
this great goal and I think in the past
few years there has just been like an
explosion of work on all three of these
areas so I'm mostly going to concentrate
on this one area over here but um
if you're asking you know why should we
study the NP hardness of mcsp well maybe
it it could be important in
understanding whether
one-way functions whether we can base
one-way functions on opinion as as we
mentioned earlier uh in the earlier
talks there are some theorems that when
you stake them they have seemingly
nothing to do with meta complexity like
uh but they're uh strong lower bounds
for up imply average case lower bounds
and stuff like this and here's another
question P naught equal to NP does that
imply one-way functions I guess where
meta complexity is popping up as a tool
um
so this is a this is another motivation
for understanding the NP completeness
not just the intractability
and um
well you know the last main motivation
that I want to talk about is kind of a
personal motivation uh this is so I got
this this is the most serious picture of
me that I could find to describe my
personal information really conveys uh
so to me I think
understanding this question whether mcsp
is empty heart is related to like
another long-standing problem which is
proving circuit lower bounds
and to me I think well uh okay let me do
this part first to me
in circuit complexity when you look at
pretty much any open question either
it's been open for 30 years or it's all
it was solved in the 90s you know uh and
so it's really good to have new
questions to ask and in particular
tractable intermediate problems
and so this question of understanding
you know whether mcsp is going to be
complete or whether the formula version
of mcsp is MP complete or these various
questions about mcspeed they give you
tractable intermediate questions or
seemingly tractable intermediate
questions that let you study okay can I
use my formula lower bounds to do this
can I use my constant circuit lower
bounds to do this and by doing this I
think it it helps kind of give you these
intermediate problems that let you
attack this area and hopefully develop
new tools and so to me that's that's one
of the
motivations of studying mcsp and that's
what really drew me to the area and you
know this is kind of vague that proving
hardness for mcspeak can lead to new
circuit lower bounds I'll give you a
concrete example of this later where
that kind of happened
but uh yes those are those are pretty
much the motivations for why you want to
improve hardness of mcsp so let me just
recap them really quickly
so one is eliminate heuristica another
base one-way functions on P versus MP
discover new circuit lower bounds and uh
the last thing I think is curiosity I
didn't talk about this so much but I
mean it's a very simple Pro I mean it's
a very basic problem uh it's been
studied since the 1950s and you know
unlike thousands of other problems
alluded our ability to prove that it's
NP complete or or not np-complete and uh
I think it's
it seems like a basic scientific
question we want to know the answer to
and I think I want to know the answer to
it you've all come to this
meta-complexity Workshop so presumably
you have some interest in this I think
Levin wants to know the answer to this
uh after all these years so okay all
right so is there any questions about
this motivation uh
it was pretty high level stuff so
okay cool
so
when I was designing how I wanted to
present this talk uh I was thinking
about whether I want to tell you about
results first the progress we've made
whether I want to tell you about
barriers first and it was a tough thing
to resolve but I ended up going with
barriers first because what I want to do
is I want to tell you about the barriers
and I want to tell you about what
techniques that might Inspire and then
when we talk about results I can show
you okay here's where we use this
technique here's where we use this
technique inspired by the barriers so
that's my goal here I want to tell you a
little bit about the barriers why this
problem is hard to resolve and and
that's going to kind of suggest some
techniques that we're going to see in
the results section so this is uh why
has it been so difficult
okay so one of the primary conclusions I
think of mcsp research over the past uh
many years has been the limits of
deterministic reductions and this has a
pretty natural intuition
um
so unfortunately the sad state of
circuit complexity is that we don't know
explicit part functions
I've tried uh which isn't saying much
but uh many people have tried and
unfortunately we don't we don't know
whether explicit functions require large
circuits and for the purpose of proving
that mcsp's NPR This is particularly
annoying
because it means we we don't really have
non-trivial known senses of mcsp like we
don't know how to produce like a single
no instance of mcsp at least in a
uniform way such that
um it can't be solved like kind of
really quickly by Brute Force algorithm
and uh you know there are various ways
you can formalize it but
the conclusion of this is it's going to
be really hard to design a reduction
with this constraint if you don't know
what a single hard instance of the
problem like how are you going to get a
reduction from sat to this problem it
seems really difficult and there are
many Works um I think these Works uh uh
if particularly uh good
consequences that basically show that if
you had a deterministic polynomial time
reduction you know under various guises
many one Turing and so on that's going
to require some sort of breakthrough
something that uh maybe need be at
circuit lower balance or X not equal to
zpp and in fact I'll give you two
examples of these theorems so um this is
by Marianne Williams any many one
deterministic reduction from sat to mcsp
that's going to imply X not inclusive
PPP for the purposes of this talk it
doesn't really matter what that problem
is it's just some long-standing open
question we believe to answer that
question is true
um well we don't know how to show it so
this is an example of how getting
the deterministic reduction that the
supplements we think is is beyond us
right now and and there are some
extensions uh to Turing reductions work
done by Saxon Santana which also showed
that implies so circuit lower bounds and
there are various other results here I
don't want to list all of them but I
think the takeaway for this workshop and
when you guys are working on this is
that okay deterministic reductions that
that seems like something that's
difficult to get away with and um this
naturally points to a technique of
randomized reduction so we don't know uh
how to deterministically come up with a
circuit that requires with a function
that requires large circuits but if
you're allowed to use Randomness well I
can randomly pick a function and then
it's going to have required large
circuits by a counting argument
basically so what if we are allowed to
use randomized reductions uh what can
that can that help us in
proving empty-hardness of mcsp
and the second technique I want to talk
about here is uh sub-exponential
reductions it turns out that this logic
here that
if you had a reduction from sat to mcsp
it like forces you to kind of have
circuit lower bounds or some
new complexity breakthrough kind of
breaks down in the sub-exponential
regime and I'm going to give you some
intuition for why this is true later so
if it doesn't make perfect sense right
now don't worry about it uh ask me about
it when I come back to it I think
that'll actually probably be in the next
section uh next hour of the talk
um but but it turns out that this kind
of this this kind of logic points to
these two types us and we'll see this
later randomized reductions coming up in
some exponential time reductions
any questions about this or stuff I've
said so far
and the second burial I want to talk
about is um Oracle independent
reductions I think this is something
that hasn't played as much of a role in
the literature as
um maybe the work on deterministic
reductions but I wanted to bring this up
because there's this result that is like
the best there was this result by
hirohara which is like the closest that
we can get
to mcsp being NP hard I'm going to tell
you about it later it turns out that
this ends up being a barrier for that
result so I want to tell you a little
bit about that
you seem skeptical about it or no okay
okay
so let me tell you what an oracle
independent reduction is
um and so this is this is something
introduced by hirohara on Watanabe in
2016. and uh
basically the definition of an oracle
independent turn uh polynomial time
Turing reduction from NP to mcsp is that
this problem mcsp to the a I'll tell you
what it is later but for now it's just
some problem related to mcsp that no
matter what Oracle a you put here that
sat is in P to the mcspeed
so again I haven't told you what this
thing is but uh let me tell you about
that next but it's it's saying that uh
reduction it's not just proving that sat
is in P to the mcsp but it's also
actually proving that status in P to the
mcsp to the A and um so one thing about
this
definition that's a little weird is that
like this we're saying this is a
reduction but here this is just about
membership and sets don't worry about
that distinction for now
and um so what is this this problem mcsp
today you might be able to guess what it
is it says that if you fix some a Oracle
you'll now add a Oracle Gates into your
circuit basis so for example it should
be allowed and Gates or Gates not Gates
and a Oracle Gates so
um
these Oracle Gates could be like sat
Gates they could be qbf Gates and and
this this model was studied in Prior
papers for example by alinger Holden
cabinets and allender Berman cuski and
Mal Quebec and Ron Berger
to show hardness but uh in this Oracle
independent reduction section it was uh
interesting
and
this is different from relativeization
but let me come back to that later but
what I kind of want to say is that what
does it mean for something to be an
oracle independent reduction from NP to
mcsp it kind of means it's some
reduction that doesn't care about what
Gates you have you know as long as
they're like a finite number of gates
you can have and Gates or Gates not
Gates and then you know whatever
function you want you can add that into
your basis and my reduction doesn't care
um and so we say a reduction is Oracle
independent if
and so you can ask this uh for any
language L but I just plugged in satin
NP
are there any questions about this so
wait this is the same reduction
yeah okay so the way that I've defined
it actually the reduction isn't playing
a role it's just a question about set
membership right but you could imagine
um
uh does the same reduction show that and
in fact this is what's kind of happening
with shuichi's result that we'll talk
about later not for mcsp Star but mktp
star I think yeah so uh
all right to the quantifiers it doesn't
matter
yeah
somehow intuitively you think that you
could just uh you know for all organs
you could have an A that like targets
yeah exactly and in fact in fact that's
what they'll use this
uh right and so the barriers that they
showed is that in fact there is no
deterministic political independent
production from sat to mcsp and this is
kind of using the thing that Ian is
talking about
um specifically you could imagine
choosing some Oracle a uh that kind of
targets your reduction says it's not
going to work and um
what limitations are on the Oracle a no
no any I mean that has to be like a like
a legitimate function but it's a circuit
or like it could be it could be like SAS
it could be qdf it could be P space or
sorry it's a language it's a language
yeah
um but there has to be a decidable
language I guess I know it doesn't have
to be inside no limitations
so yeah it's really it's like uh you
know
and that's why this kind of having an
oracle independent reduction is
something that's kind of strong and
saying that like I really really don't
care about the circuit model in the
sense that like you can add any maybe
even an undecidable
um gate into your uh circuit model and
that still will get this reduction
they showed that there can be no
deterministic oral production once that
fancy of speed and they even show
barrier that this may be more
interesting uh for us is that there's no
randomized one query Oracle independent
reduction so it says like there's no
even a randomized menu one reduction uh
you can't get
it and so okay this this slide is a bit
technical
but the takeaway that I want you guys to
have if you guys try and prove hardness
for mcsp is that you're going to have to
keep this uh in mind you're going to
need to use circuit lower bounds
techniques that somehow depend uh on the
gate set in some way but it just needs
to be you know uh that doesn't work for
all oracles a or maybe you can use
multiple queries
um there so
okay
they need to take a lot of input so it
takes them and it's yeah yeah
so what you do you get I guess is you
get like an infinite number of gates for
each input but for each input length you
get one gate that solves that problem on
that input line did that make sense like
um
so all right
so what's going to happen is you're
you're gonna get
um your Gates that you're gonna allowed
to use is let's say you get or on two
inputs you get not on one input you get
um and on two inputs and you also get
might get sat on one input and then sat
on two inputs that you can all use in
this circuit does that answer your
question or
yep okay all right great yeah
any other questions yes this is for the
exact mcsp or some approximate
that's a good question actually
um
the deterministic thing probably should
work
um
for the approximation version I'd have
to think about the randomized
performance
uh but uh right I mean if you prove it
for an approximation hardness
approximation version It's Going to
Prove It for the amount of proximation
group
oh you're saying could you get stronger
hardness for the approximation version
saying if the barrier only holds for
proving that the approximation oh oh I
see no but this definitely holds for the
uh not not approximation I understand
yeah is there some reason to believe
that randomized say constant query
Oracle independent reductions have
significantly more power yes I think
this is a good this is a good question
um so one thing I should mention uh that
I was going to mention next is we we
actually do have Oracle
reductions that are not Oracle
independent so for example uh Allen
during herahar I think the mktp the debt
to a mktp reduction that's not Oracle
independent
um
but um
but right but this question of multiple
queries I think that's something that
would be important to understand with
respect to hirohara's new result on
partial mcsp like how can we make this
reduction uh not vertical independent
[Music]
sorry
okay great any more questions
yeah okay so I'll mention actually let
me uh well yeah uh let me uh talk about
that in the next part we're gonna talk
about that actually talked about that
reduction yeah
uh I think so the deterministic part
that's definitely going to be true the
randomized part I'd have to think about
it
but this is
yeah okay so the answer so Ryan's
question was there's this this problem
that I keep referring to as a partial
mcsp that Hero has made progress on
um the techniques there for partial mcsp
is actually somewhat unclear if it's
Oracle independent but for like he shows
that a lot of problems are empty like
this is
yeah it doesn't in fact it doesn't
so we can't have it against the hardness
I mean why are like determinant
introductions
deterministic reductions now the
previous barriers on the previous slide
will apply it
here we are maybe I'll move on I think
this is not such a crucial thing to
understand
um but right now but if you if you do
end up trying to attack your horror this
question I think it's something
foreign
another barrier you could imagine is uh
proving hardness for mcsb you know it
can help you eliminate heuristica and
there are some barriers related to that
there are some black box barriers and
there's some relativization barriers
but actually
um
so we have results that do get past both
of these things so as I mentioned
earlier the worst case to average case
reduction uh for NP that hirohara shows
is non-black box and this mcsp star
result that um your hearts are shown is
non-relativizing so even though these
These are barriers to eliminating
heuristica I don't think it's out of the
question that um we are actually able to
prove that the hardness needed to do it
so I I wouldn't my personal take is I
don't view these as much of a barriers
and then the the last kind of barrier
that I want to keep in mind is uh well
maybe the statement's just false that
would be a big barrier uh is it possible
that mcsp is just not NP hard and uh so
I think the general consensus at this
point is that probably the problems NPR
at least I'd venture to say that I don't
know what other people uh would say
um but I I do want to say that there is
some evidence uh maybe not strong
evidence but there is some evidence that
maybe the problem could be and NP
intermediate and so what does NP
intermediate mean NP intermediate is
some problem that's an NP but not in p
and not NP complete so it's some problem
that's difficult and it's in NP but it
just doesn't happen to be NP complete
and there's this theorem by Ladner which
says that if p is actually not equal to
NP then
uh the infinitely many uh
anti-intermediate problems exist
and mcsp I think uh was a potential
candidate and BE intermediate problem
for a while and there's some reasons for
that so one result that shows mcsp uh
kind of works towards mcsp being MP
intermediate depending on how you define
it is this result by Marian Williams
which shows that under certain types of
reductions called projections which we
actually saw earlier today
uh
mcsp is just unconditionally not and be
hard
and so if you define your NP hardness
with respect to these relatively weak
reductions which I should say like
almost any NP complete problem that you
name is going to be NP complete under
these uh n to the point four nine times
projections projections I think like in
that paper the only counter example you
guys could or problem you can do is like
subset sum or something like that
so
but almost every other NP complete
problem that we know is going to be uh
np-complete not just on your end to the
point four nine time projections but
like poly log time projections so
but to me I mean my opinion on this is
this is really about uh the weakness of
these
reductions more than the uh
more than the NP intermediate problem
and P intermedieness of mcsp but uh you
know that's my take I mean obviously you
could think the other way or not
and uh another result that I want to
mention is is by allender and hirohara
who showed that if you take a really
really large approximation to mcsb
uh and one-way functions exist then um
this problem is going to be NP
intermediate
and
this is cool because they dressed on
this like one-way function assumption
you can show that this problem is not NP
intermediate
error is NP intermediate but I want to
stress that this is maybe not so
surprising because like under eth this
is like this is such a large
approximation that even like brute
forcing
um the answer is going to is going to
break eth so this is a problem that
maybe you'd expect
okay so what's the definition of
intermediate like what what's what type
of reductions do you consider
non-black box also
I see I see you're saying uh yeah I
guess to really Define NP intermediate
uh usually it's defined with perspective
I guess
he said uh
wouldn't you have also
like if you play with barometers
wouldn't you have also the sound
barrients of societies and BE
intermediate like if I would say Saturn
and do the little or one variables it's
probably yeah based on a similar eth uh
thing at least
because I cannot reduce certain n
variables and
exactly
improve similar results I think in this
paper you mentioned you can prove
similar results for tweak as well right
I'm having trouble here oh sorry oh yeah
it's not not so important but uh yeah
so just as a recap for barriers uh
for deterministic reductions we know
it's going to require a breakthrough so
you're probably going to need to use
randomness
Oracle independent reductions you're
probably going to need some facts about
the gate set in some way but this is not
going to be such an exotic thing we have
we have reductions which are not Oracle
independent and there is some limited uh
evidence that the problem is
so
uh now I'm going to talk about progress
we have towards showing that the mcsp is
NP hard and for various problems is
there any questions about uh the stuff
I've talked about so far yeah Alex yeah
is there a universe in which you get NP
hardness with respect to rent randomized
reductions but the problem is not envy
hard with respect to deterministic
reductions or is it more of a question
of what we're capable of proving does
that question make sense yeah uh overall
okay let me give you an answer and uh
let me see if it answers your question
so if you believe in Strong Enough
circuit lower bounds like a randomized
reduction is going to imply that's good
okay so so that is a question of what we
can prove yeah just a question about
what we could do or I mean assuming it
is
function
s
yeah
this is a I think this is a great
question I I think um so as far as I
know there is no candidate Construction
in fact for some time I spent some time
I trying to answer the question like can
I come up with any conjecture you know
let it be ridiculous you know like the
the uh the optimal circuit for doing
something looks exactly like this and
then based on that can I prove mcsp as
NP heart and I you know I wasn't able to
do it I think it's an interesting
question can you come up with even a
contrived hypothesis that isn't like
obviously like mcsp's empty hard which
would imply that mcsp's NPR is there any
like even if I let you make a reasonable
conjecture can you can you show it so
that as far as I know there's no
candidate example and I think that's an
interesting question
any other questions
and I think that brings us to our first
trivia segment
um and so as you can see over here we
have a list of wonderful prizes that you
are not allowed to eat in this room I
have been told so but you can take them
home with you uh so if you're interested
in any of these prizes uh you're gonna
have to answer my questions
so so this is trivia about uh Euros
hermanus who sadly passed away in the
past year I think
and so harmonics as I mentioned earlier
uh was one of the co-authors on the on
this paper that introduced time classes
and space classes in the time hierarchy
theorem and so my question is uh one
heart Madison Stearns proved the time
hierarchy theorem what was heart
modest's affiliation no don't don't
shout out the answer yeah there's gonna
be multiple choice we're gonna we're
gonna have uh yeah all right so a
Cornell
B IBM
C General Electric D Rutgers so uh who
thinks the answer is a raise your hand
remember there's there's cash on the
line I mean not count non-cash prizes
online all right Greg's thinking hey who
who thinks B IBM
all right we got some
um okay I guess what I'm gonna do is I
need to uh so Greg what's your what's
your opinion or opinion for Cornell
we'll see you have any logic behind that
I mean I know he was at Cornell for a
while uh it seems like with high
probability you reserve back then just
because they have intro depending at the
other places but I'm not 100 sure okay
okay who thinks B who are the people who
thought B oh they're all gone okay okay
what's your do you have any uh reason
for choosing okay but you but you think
B okay you are the people who are gonna
get the prizes by the way so uh if you
guys are right who thinks C General
Electric
oh okay
uh all right who do I want uh who wants
to be the representative okay Oliver do
you have any logic uh like we wouldn't
be there if that wasn't the answer
don't play the gameplay
[Laughter]
all right all right all right so the
answer was General Electric this uh was
kind of surprising to me I just found
this out recently uh I was reading to
you there's an excellent obituary on
Cornell's page and uh it talks about how
he was at General Electric and I think
this is something that's kind of funny
that the birth of computational
complexity occurred at a General
Electrics lab I've never heard of it I
didn't even know know that they did
research like that I think that's very
cool
um so Oliver I think you were the person
what prize would you like from the list
I'm enjoying okay all right
oh
all right we got got one more trivia
question before we resume this one's
about Albert Meyer
um so Albert Meyer introduced the
pulmonary hierarchy along with Larry
stockmere
you graduated from PhD his PhD in
Harvard in 1972. what year did he become
faculty at MIT is it a 1969 raise your
hand
no one thinks no one thinks a all right
is it B 1971 all right we got a couple
we got a couple okay you have a reason
for this
yeah should I just answer okay okay 19.
it's 1972.
what well all right Greg you have uh any
reason because I didn't see anyone else
raising their hands for this
some chance of getting the candy all
right and uh D 1973
all right answer a 1969.
so I don't so I have sources for this
the source is uh the MIT website as long
as the mass as well as the math
genealogy page and Wikipedia I have no
idea how this happened
um if I maybe somebody here knows the
story I guess not because nobody chose
hey
um well he graduated from a PhD in 1972
And as far as I can tell he became
faculty at MIT in 1969 so that's a
inspiring story to us all I think
and uh so one more question when did
Maya's first PhD student
um who thinks a 1969.
all right do you have a logic
oh
uh being 1971.
what's it do you have logic it will be
fun if you graduate he's doing graduate
first uh 1972
uh
his first student was Albert Meyer
himself
[Laughter]
all right I guess
all right give me uh yeah I mean I also
raised my hand for 1972 but he didn't
call on me
okay so the answer is 1972. uh I'm
curious to know whether how far from his
own graduation his student graduated
again this is based on the math
genealogy project so those are my
sources if somebody can figure out like
the story behind this I'd be I think
it'd be very fascinating and which can
you see over there yes which uh oh I
should cross off some stuff what did you
get Oliver you got the Almond Joy yeah
all right that's gone
what's in the back of the room actually
it's gone uh and Ian what would you like
I will take I think
okay
okay
um
right okay there you go these are two
pieces not two pints
I was just that's my roommate over there
France so if I hear about that later
um okay so I'm gonna talk for like
another five minutes and then we can uh
disperse
so I'm going to tell you a little bit
about the progress to hardness and the
things that I want to convey to you
about
the progress we've made on proving the
NP hardness of mcsp is that there's kind
of like three prongs of attack
um in fact really there's two prongs of
attack and and this thing is something I
want to mention because that's where the
field has kind of uh gone I'm going to
give you an opinion on this and uh
what I'm going to talk about right now
is kind of cryptographic hardness
results and these cryptographic
Cardinals results they're kind of older
results and seemingly they're not so
related to the NP hardness of mcsp but
as we'll see later it seems It's
the way that the fields and techniques
are moving it seems like cryptography is
becoming more and more important to
proving NP hardness at mcsp so that's
why I want to tell you a little bit
about this uh cryptographic approach to
proving hardness for mcsb so it's with
the motivation of understanding NP
hardness in the back of our mind
so this is something that we've actually
seen a a couple times now uh that
one-way functions imply that mcsp is
intractable but let me just walk you
through it again because we're going to
use it in the next slide as well
so there's this theorem
um
I guess so
who you credit to uh it's uh it's
cabinets inside who redefine the mcsp
problem uh after many years uh observed
it and I guess they credit rasp Rob and
rudich and some people credit as well
anyway there's this uh there's this
theorem that if one-way functions exist
then mcsp is not in p
and let me just
mention I don't think this has been
mentioned previously but this actually
shows like really strong
inapproximability of mcsp at least under
cryptographic assumption basically if
you uh depending on how strong of
cryptography you believe in do you
believe in like sub-existentially secure
one-way functions maybe even
exponentially secure one-way functions
uh if you believe that like the best
possible one-way functions exist you're
essentially gonna this theorem is gonna
show that mcspe
C is basically completely an
approximable uh if the Brute Force
algorithm is pretty much optimal so uh
we'll see that now I'm going to recap
some of the proof uh so the proof idea
is as follows
uh
if one-way functions exist
then they're going to improvise some
pseudorandom set this is going to be
based on like if you're familiar with
cryptography it's going to take your
one-way function turn it into a prg take
your prg turn it into a prf uh and then
after that you take you can take like an
initial segment of the prf but you're
not familiar with that don't worry about
it you're uh you basically get a
pseudo-random set of Truth tables with
the following properties
I'm about to define it
uh one one-way functions apply the
existence of a pseudo random set of
ended truth tables so this is just some
set of Truth tables with the following
two properties okay so these are going
to be ended two tables every uh truth
table in this set has low circuit
complexity so let's say complexity n to
the point zero one you can make that
constant as small as you want and the
second property is that they're going to
be pseudorandom that no poly enzyme
algorithm can distinguish uh when you
take a uniform element of s uh from a
uniformly random n bit string so
cryptography just guarantees this if
you're not familiar with cryptography
then you can take it on faith otherwise
that he did do the construction uh via
ggm and Hill
and now okay we're pretty much set up to
attack this as uh Valentine said earlier
we can kill the prg with mcsp
e a random string has uh complexity n to
the one minus little o of one
so now since uh every string in this set
has low complexity and a random string
has high complexity mcsp can distinguish
this set from random and so by the
pseudor randomness of this set mcsp
cannot have a polyan Time algorithm
and um if you assume you have
sub-exponential one-way functions now
you'll get that instead of there's no
polynomial time algorithm there's no sub
exponential time algorithm
and you'll get that there's no selection
multiple time algorithm from CSP and
notably in this proof I just want to
emphasize that even this question that I
mentioned earlier about like order
versus chaos it shows that this is
intractable
so is this like the main source
this this easier problem is still NP
hard are there other things yeah I think
I think this is the main source of uh in
fact uh yeah I think we're at on the
hard NP hardness standpoint we haven't
really gotten to the point where we can
talk about this we're getting closer I
think in the past few years like uh yeah
okay I'll talk about it later but this
is the main source of hardness
and uh so there's this this this as I
mentioned earlier there's this technique
that's being used more and more in these
hardness reductions which is using
cryptographic ideas I think this is the
first place where cryptographic ideas
prove the intractability of mcsp
Eed okay and then I also want to mention
this hardness for statistical zero
knowledge so if you're not familiar with
statistical zero knowledge maybe you're
familiar with zero knowledge statistical
zero knowledge just talks about
um some version of zero knowledge we
care about information theoretic
security if you don't if you don't know
what zero knowledge is or if you don't
know what information theoretic zero
knowledge would mean don't worry about
it I'll just give you some example of
some problems in them uh so graph
isomorphism is probably the most famous
problem but there's also a bunch of
cryptographic problems like quadratic
quadratic residuosity approximate story
sector problem some version of discrete
log so all these problems that we think
are cryptographically harder in sck
and SDK is some class that under widely
believed de-randomization assumptions is
in in danger
and um Hollander and Daw showed that
every problem in sck reduces to mcsp and
we heard a little bit about this this
morning not quite
um
not quite this theorem statement but a
version of it and
um this right now for mcsp proper the
original version of mcsp this is
basically the best hardness we know
under the usual types of Black Box
reductions is this fast SDK which is
probably not uh probably outside of P if
you believe in this various type of
Photography that everything in SDK
reduces to mcsp
foreign
I'll tell you like briefly like one of
the ideas behind this reduction uh and
this is going to be like very brief
there's this complete problem for SDK
there are many complete problems but one
complete problem basically says you hand
me two circuits and either those two
circuits the distribution induced by
them is is basically the same their
statistical distance is small or their
range is rarely intersect on average
whatever that means so you either get
two circuits whose range is intersect a
lot of the time or that they don't
intersect a lot all the time
and then to all the intuition I'm going
to give you is to solve this complete
problem you can use mcsp's ability to
invert one-way functions to test whether
circuits have similar ranges or not so
the idea is you know you run the circuit
on one input you get some element that's
in the range of the first second first
circuit then you use mcsp's ability to
invert functions to test whether that's
in the range of the second circuit and
things are kind of set up nicely so that
you can carry this out there are some
more details about this but this is like
an example of how you use mcsp's ability
to invert one-way functions in order to
get hardness
sorry yes
can we just strictly use results that is
hardness basically implies
qualifications yeah under the previous
results and then then you yeah yeah so
another way to do this I guess this is
result by Australia which says that uh
if uh okay let me get the direction
what's the direction
by 20 functions yeah exactly you need
average
but when it functions are good enough
for freaking out with mcsp yeah yeah
that's another one here yeah
exactly and um and this is another uh or
this is an example again of using
randomized reductions the randomness
here is used to like sample from the
distributions and convert this ability
to invert one-way functions is some sort
of average case notion so you're going
to need to be able to need to use
Randomness and uh this is a
another example where we're using
cryptographic tools to understand the
complexity of mcsp so these are two
techniques that I want to emphasize and
um I think that will be
the stopping point for this talk
um
okay let me think is there anything else
that I want to mention about sck
yeah okay that's it and uh are there any
questions
excellent questions
any questions for this guy all right
all right uh well see you again